Hey Youtuber's it's Charlie.
We have new Firestorm footage and Danielle
Panabaker was talking about Killer Frost as
well as Gorilla Grodd things happening, so
I felt like it demanded a video!
I'm also gonna be doing the Q&A at the end
of this too so here's the deal with Gorilla
Grodd did Danielle Panabaker was just doing
a whole bunch of press on a bunch of different
outlets so what she said is is that the Grodd
story this year chummy she didn't say exactly
when it's coming but she said it's going to
be like this King Kong allegory where she'll
play like the and Darrow character so just
your picture Gorilla Grodd jumping around
town over buildings trying to hold her in
his hand rewind to last year that the Grodd
lives episode I think it was 21 where they
have general Eiling in the present and Grodd
is speaking through his lips and he says Kate
good so that means that Grodd likes Caitlin
snow but probably just because she treated
them really well when he was a test subject
maybe she just brought him big belly burgers
we know he doesn't like bananas that's what's
going on with Grodd this year so I'd I don't
think were gonna see so LaVar I don't think
were gonna see Gorilla city I think is just
going to be another standalone Grodd episode
but I'm really curious to see is a beginner
because earth two in the portal the speed
got have you want to think about it is such
a big deal like a running plot like I'm curious
to see if Grodd story overlaps with out like
a Grodd finds out about the earth two portal
and tries to do something with it within the
big thing is that Furia firestorm so hears
was going on is going to be like a multiple
firestorm Battle Royale episode we know now
that this character is going to be Jack's
Jackson they actually changed his name again
originally it was just Jay Jackson that a
lot of people thought it might be a recast
version of Jason Rusch the the thing that
I think they're doing the the reason I think
that they're not using Jason Rusch is just
because they want to keep it as simple as
possible but if you want to recast the actor
but they don't think that the actor that they
already cast a Jason Rusch is right for the
tone of legends of tomorrow like they want
a stronger actor and they don't want to recast
so that might be why they created this new
character because they want this actor he
was in attack the block with John Boyega who's
burning it up in the Star Wars universe right
now so I think they wanted him like they felt
like you would be the perfect firestorm character
but there was an issue with the Jason Rusch
names the like why don't we just create a
new firestorm there is a point in the comics
went when a bunch of people all over the world
try to get their hands on Martin Stein's technology
to create firestorms for their own select
each nation has their own version of firestorm
is big debacle the new 52 see you can look
at it from the perspective that there have
been many many people who have been part of
a firestorm matrix and yes brawny will come
back but they didn't say how we come back
I'm I'm guessing either in a flashback or
earth two Ronnie will be seen somehow and
this may have been another case where like
were Robbie Amell just wasn't available to
do legends of tomorrow because he's doing
so many movies so the like okay we want to
use firestorm but we can't use Robbie Amell
so why don't we just do the transition to
the next version of the character they actually
have the actors onset now from arrow the flash
in legends of tomorrow shooting all three
shows logistically behind the scenes is kind
of a nightmare shooting three shows the same
time with all the same actors but it is gonna
look freaking awesome whatever he gets there
next year and it should air sometime in January
I don't know exactly how many episodes firestorm
is going to be in this year but presumably
they brought Tom Cavanagh back like Harrison
wells came to the portal so that Martin Stein
can go away like they want to have that role
filled in the casket what they want like the
older advisor character so they're bringing
back Tom Cavanagh kind like passing the torch
from Martin Stein Harrison wells in case you
didn't hear me talk about it in my flash episode
three video Harrison wells of earth two is
not evil he's not going to be zoom is just
a super big dickhead Grant Gustin when he
was talking about the character just said
he was a total douchebag but he is the original
version of Harrison wells of earth two he's
not going to be a Eobard in disguise but Matt
Letscherthe guy who played a bar Thawne before
he can like sucked in the DNA of Harrison
wells he's going to be back to Eddie is going
to be back to but we don't know how that's
gonna work either presumably at all the flashbacks
and earth two stuff will get the real question
time Junior Sanchez asks does blue lightning
at the stadium the reverse flash versus the
flash fight have anything to do with Prof.
zoom in flash or anyone else so I think you
might be talking about zoom specifically like
Prof. zoom in zoomer two different characters
so if you are asking about blue lightning
zoom during season one know that just a coincidence
there have been times in the comics for zoom
in Prof. zoom team up to work together reluctantly
like Prof. zoom hates the crap out of zoom
but I'd I don't think that was what they were
trying to do in season one of the flash it
was just meant to be a LaVar Thawne Prof.
zoom and ask another been a lot of theories
about who zoom is I mean it still hasn't been
confirmed that we still will find out is beneath
the mask but they keep referring to him using
male pronouns so I don't think that it is
a female character is questionable freak Castille
asks I want to see a race between Jay and
Wally soon are you isomers talk about all
the flash is just as have a race I do think
that they will have that moment like this
warm a moment at the end of the season when
they all have a race together like Halo scene
is the fastest Jay is still trying to get
his powers back but they just introduce the
idea of this quark matter like the special
matter that's involved in getting back through
the portal you think that's going to be critical
to getting Jay's powers back but they still
don't know how zoom took his powers like I
mean that's one of the speed force abilities
most speedsters can give intakes be Wally
West was able to do in the comics but they
might change the explanation just for the
TV show there was changes a few minor things
about the comics so just don't don't assume
comic book rules when it comes to giving and
taking speed so once everybody gets there
speed back in once Wally West gets his powers
and we will probably see team flash bro down
next question Ballantyne asks do you think
that Henry Allen from earth two could be zoom
maybe earth two Henry Allen kidnapped and
killed Barry's father and took his place "so
you're talking about like Henry on from Earth
to coming to Earth one and then killing Barry's
dad in the prisoner like outside of the prison
and then just walking around asses that pertain
to be him the reason I don't think that's
the case although it's a really awesome idea
I'd I love to see Jon Wesley Shipp be the
villain of the season he looks like he's about
the same size as Jay Garrick and Jay Garrick
is pretty tall but until we get some more
evidence I mean it's the world on a couple
episodes in so will get a lot more evidence
about what zoom is up to what he's doing and
why he wants to be the fastest once we learn
those things level of some better theory craft
and material but the reason I think that he
is a West is because season one was all about
Barry fixing his family like you wanted to
get his data prison save his mother he accomplished
that now in season two whose family is broken
will I irises family is broken so it's all
about fixing that family so I think that it
might be a West from earth two trying to fix
that the because it's her to its was really
hard to tell I mean it could totally be evil
version of Barry the really interesting thing
I think this is telling is that none of the
writers none of the actors have talked about
the characters meeting themselves on earth
to select is there in earth two version of
Barry or is he dead like what's going on so
they will also have to meet other versions
of the characters from earth two before we
can say you know zoom is XYZ character next
question HK Harpster asks I think Wally is
gonna come midseason finally yet is interesting
we we don't know which episode he's going
to debut in in the really interesting thing
is is that Jay Garrick I guess he hasn't met
the West yet so I'm really interested to see
if Wally is from earth two and Jay Garrick
means detective West on Earth one needs like
okay I've met I met your son and he's like
what I don't have a son next question Noah
plays asks would've zoom is Barry from the
future when he was blue trying to kill all
the speedsters to stop something like when
he try to kill his past self so you talking
about the new 52 plot line the the reason
I don't think that zoom is from the future
now is because everything is about like different
choices different versions of the character
so I think that zoom is just a different version
of a character the we already know it's like
season one was all about time travel season
two is all about alternate versions of characters
so I just I think that zoom is going to flow
from that thank you so much for something
questions everyone and congratulations to
nova blast you went this week's reverse flash
ring be sure to private message me on the
back and my channels and get your contact
info the next round of the giveaway will will
start next Tuesday whenever I post my flash
episode four video just just like normal and
I'm still behind on Gotham I'm trying to get
that out as soon as possible hopefully I'll
get it out before Dr. who starts tomorrow
in the meantime acacias haven't seen it I
just posted like the full Jessica Jones trailer
is like a full Two and a Half Minute trailer
click here to watch that like five or six
times it's gonna be so dark and you can click
here for this week's episode of arrow and
the flash thank you so much watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tomorrow!